bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france leur emmanuel macron
qualifie donc de mon temps à les propos
du premier ministre malien de transition
ses propos le mali reproche à la france
une espèce d'abandon en plein vol
pourquoi ce sentiment finalement par le
mali d'avoir été lâché par la france
alors je bonjour merci pour l'invitation
tout d'abord je pense que ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan récemment
permet aux autorités maliennes de la
transition de vouloir chercher à pallier
dans l'avenir si barkan devait quitter
ou réduire son effectif de trouver de
nouveaux partenaires c'est en cela que
tu es déjà eu des rapprochements avec
des partenaires étrangers outre la
france où les nids
lesquels justement quel vers quel
partenaire naturellement l'avant le mali
va t-il se tourner puisqu'ils ne se sent
abandonnés par la france
alors le temps à bon ton peut-être est
un peu trop fort parce que par kohn est
toujours en place et la france est un
partenaire historique dit stratégiques
du mali le terme abonde en plein vol -
mon sens est un peu fort pour l'instant
barkan comme je le disais tantôt par
kandela est en passe on verra d'ici là
ce qui il ya une réduction d'effectifs
ou si c'est la fin de l'engagement de
barkan et des forces françaises dans
celles mais pour la brûlures ce n'est
pas le cas et aujourd'hui on reparle de
certaines structures privées russes qui
devrait venir mais ce sont des infos ou
pas même des rumeurs pour l'instant rien
n'est confirmé
je pense qu'on s'emballe peut-être un
peu trop vite et aujourd'hui je pense
que monsieur marcoux les propos qu'il a
tenus à l'encontre du premier ministre
les tripes titre on dit sont en général
ne sont pas de nature à adoucir déroule
entre nos deux pays dit
qu'on ne peut pas tenir il devrait faire
preuve d'une certaine hauteur de vue et
comprendre l'exaspération hop le malien
bascule huit ans de présence de forces
étrangères à peu près trente mille
hommes en additionnant barkan
les forces des forces maliennes et aux
initiales avaient à peu près 30 min de
8,9 en mai 80% du territoire est occupé
voire même des zones qui étaient sans
aide ce hors conflit commence
aujourd'hui à est un partez donc qui dit
non non pour les maliens et pro ministre
n'a fait que relater les propos des deux
le ressenti est pas une majorité malien
à fait normal et en tant que tu es là et
magna leur macron affirmant je le cite
je sais que les maliens ne pense pas ça
en parlant d' abandon pourquoi la france
estime t-elle savoir ce que les maliens
veulent
alors servi je pense que ils ont les
dents des agents sur place ils ont dit
aux autres qu'on leur donne qui sont pas
vraiment véridique et il réussit sur un
petit rappel vous savez quand d'abord ce
qu'est serval qui arrivait dès que une
fois qu'on a libéré une partie du centre
du mardi est le leur arrivée à kidal on
demande aux forces maliennes de rester à
la porte vous savez c'est des choses qui
est dans la mémoire des maliens c'est
pas aussi au débarquement de des
américains en normandie on leur demande
de rester de se cantonner juste au
lendemain de force de leclerc de se
cantonner au niveau des plages de
normandie et de ne pas continuer et
laisser les américains rentrée ouais
c'est d'ailleurs cet aspect a choqué la
et oui non moi je peux vous le garantir
et ces parlementaires maliens j'ai signé
pour plus près de la population au
quotidien il faut dire que les propos
tenus par le premier ministre c'est le
ressenti de l'écrasante majorité des
maliens et même si je le disais si ça ne
tenait qu'à moi j'aurais pas utilisé
peut-être comme terme de l'or comme
élément de langage abandonnant paix en
vol parce que nous y sommes pas encore
alors concrètement pour comprendre selon
la france il s'agit d'une transformation
du dispositif militaire rosell et ça
constitue ni un départ à nîmes décision
unilatérale concrètement ça veut dire
quoi cette transformation le dispositif
militaire
alors il ya que madame par lee qui
pourrait vous apporter cette réponse de
manière de manière claire et avec des
paiements beaucoup plus probant que moi
parlementaires maliens vous savez et
d'où justement on ne va pas attendre à
la dernière minute comme ça je répète
encore comme ça s'est passé pour
l'afghanistan de se trouver au pied du
mur et est aujourd'hui on a déjà 80% du
territoire malien que denrée qui n'est
pas sous le contrôle de l'armée malienne
alors imaginez si la france qui est un
soutien depuis huit ans s'en va ou deux
nuls me réduit ses effectifs
saleh d'être le seul existant comme
c'est fait pour le cas au départ des
valeurs étaient en afghanistan
s'abaisser c'est pas que le mali
d'ailleurs c'est toute la sous région
c'est le père qui n'a ses deux uniques
hier on a vu encore de la zone des trois
frontières une serre sont très très
compliqué oui la france le mali ne
chasse pas le mali dont le veut la
france il n'est pas les monnaies qui
sache les manières c'est la france qui
décide de se désengager du secteur de
d'un certain nombre de contagion des
certaines zones et qu'elle avait ce
contrôle où il n'y a pas de sentiment
anti français comme certains veulent le
faire croire mais a surtout des
interrogations légitimes au but 2 au
bout de neuf ans de guerre et je
rappelle quand même que la france est
une puissance nucléaire dont catella
engagé parce ce que j'appelle moi des
bandits de grand chemin et des pieds
nickelés lie la france n'arrive toujours
pas il dit encore 1,30 nous sommes à +
des forces maliennes ray ça laisse
beaucoup de questions en suspens où les
questions restant seront plus des gens
commencent à douter une certaine
sincérité de cet engagement
monsieur mouillé a cessé merci en tout
cas d'avoir été en direct sur rt
français d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes parlementaire
et membre du conseil national de
transition du magny merci à vous